hello everyone what a super evening
we're having looks fantastic the people
are enthusiastic and it's lovely to see
so many people
tonight to support their favorite
personality
and I hope those who don't actually win
enough too disappointed it's taking part
that cat's butt well done to those who
follow
the senior men here
ok now I'm [ __ ] around hold on the
volunteer of the year teen resistant
castle there's a really great evening
very professionally run and I'm really
pleased to be awarded this for my
efforts I'm like Leslie thank mid devon
cycler great guys in there then to do
those nice taking it as how you feel
about stealing your orders well it's
important unexpected I'm really why
don't I love it and I really believe in
the walks are going now i wouldn'ta
choose to the elderly and disabled for
one hour Thursday and then first walk on
Wednesday and they're all going so well
and it's just so nice to see you elderly
people out from 94 to nine months we
have them on a Tuesday and is absolutely
wonderful cuz I me okay you say thank
you for my award this evening for the
unexpected compare of the Year award
that special award which is brilliant
hues we've had a really good night
tonight man so well well dinner thing is
Azam everyone wants comes up and goes
all you did a fantastic job but the
thing is as I say to you I just shut up
and read the script so it was quite easy
for me so I think you should take all
this away then no I'm having no no no no
I can add it to my many trophies at
Mosby towers okay now you're going to go
and timbi sports personality was just an
excellent showcase of everything that's
good about sporting team which as south
dartmouth community college sports
college and the hub of the school sport
partnership we really value these awards
and you can see from the amount of
nominees that have come from different
schools primary schools secondary
schools all the students younger
students ex-students people involved in
local community sports clubs that we
really value these awards and that's why
so many people involved in a school
within our schools for can't you being
nominated for awards